ganz kurz wir haben gerade gehört joe
biden hat die meisten stimmen jetzt
schon bekommen die jemals einer in einer
wahl bekommen konnte was für eine
aussagekraft hat das tatsächlich das hat
natürlich schon gewisse aussagekraft
die wahlbeteiligung bei sehr sehr hoch
wird verglichen mit dem jahr 1900 als
rund 73 prozent der amerikaner zur wahl
gegangen sind aber amerika wächst seit
jahren seit jahrzehnten muss man sagen
menschen wohl in amerika es gibt viel
zuwanderung und da ist natürlich kein
wunder bei über 300 millionen einwohner
mittlerweile das natürlich auch
sukzessive die zahl derjenigen steigt
die wehen oder zur wahl auch gehen von
daher das ist ein gutes ergebnis für joe
biden ganz klar er hat so viele stimmen
wirklich wie nie zuvor zur zeit liegt
ungefähr drei millionen stimmen vor
trump man muss es natürlich immer im
verhältnis zur gesamtbevölkerung sehen
und da liegt beiden ungefähr auf einem
niveau was man 1900 schon mal erreicht
hat jetzt hat sich die beiden ja schon
mehrfach in dieser wahl geäußert in
dieser weihnachtszeit ich fast gesagt
die sich jetzt sehr sehr lange zieht
bereits sein
wir wollen uns noch einmal schauen was
er zur deutschen zeit gestern am späten
abend gesagt hat und vor allem die
kernaussage natürlich auch dieses mal
ist keine überraschung jede stimme muss
gezählt werden denn jede stimme zählt
ich bin nicht hier um bekannt zu geben
dass wir gewonnen haben aber ich bin
hier um zu berichten dass wenn die
auszählung beendet ist wir glauben dass
wir die gewinner sein werden mit allen
ausgezählten stimmen haben wir das
konzert mit 20.000 stimmen vorsprung
gewonnen
praktisch die gleiche spanne mit den
tramp den start vor vier jahren gewonnen
hat in michigan führen wir mit über
35.000 stimmen und der abstand wächst
eine wesentlich größere spanne als
präsident trump michigan 2016 gewonnen
hatte michigan wird eine abstimmung weit
beenden vielleicht schon am heutigen tag
und ich habe ein sehr gutes gefühl
pennsylvania wir haben arizona umgedreht
und den zweiten distrikt von nebraska
von besonderer bedeutung für mich ist
dass wir mit der mehrheit der amerikaner
gewonnen haben und jede angabe zeigt
dass die mehrheit größer wird
mit einem vorsprung bei der
volksabstimmung mit fast drei millionen
stimmen
und jeder angabe zeigt dass dieser
ebenfalls steigen wird
in der tat inszenierte harris und ich
auf dem weg mehr stimmen zu gewinnen als
zuvor in der geschichte dieses landes
wir führen den wahlkampf als demokraten
aber ich werde als amerikanischer
präsident regieren präsidentschaft an
sich ist keine parteiische institution
es ist das eine amt in diesem land das
jeden repräsentiert und sie fordert eine
fürsorgepflicht für alle amerikaner
und das ist genau das was ich tun werde
ich werde genauso hart für jene arbeiten
die nicht für mich gestimmt haben wie
für jene die für mich gestimmt haben
jetzt muss jede stimme gezählt werden
niemand nimmt uns die demokratie weg
niemals
wir das volk werden nicht zum schweigen
gebracht wie das volk werden nicht
schikaniert werden wie das volk werden
nicht aufgeben
meine freunde ich bin selbstbewusst das
für siegreich sein werden aber dies ist
nicht mein sieg oder unser sich allein
es wird ein sieg für die amerikaner für
die demokratie für die usa und wird
keine blauen oder roten staaten geben
wenn wir gewinnen nur die vereinigten
staaten von amerika wir sind bild und
wir liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren